what you are bringing up is not relevant
it has everything to do with they're not
on the
same let's let people talk for like at
Le when I want to talk I get interrupted
so no we're not going to do that you're
interrupting everyone let's I just want
this question answered this is the 114th
episode of middleground and we want you
to help us decide what the next 114
episodes will be join our middleground
patreon community and make middle ground
with
us
the other side is
brainwashed can the agrees please step
forward I think brainwash is a strong
word but I also obviously step forward I
was raised Muslim I'm Iranian my mom's
side of the family especially a lot of
Iranians they felt like they just had to
become Muslim to obviously like adhere
and it's extreme what they're doing in
Iran obviously I'm not comparing but I
guess with brainwash I also went to an
Islamic school so my really devout
Muslim friends it feels like brainwash I
have a friend who's hijabi and I I just
like for her it feels like it wasn't a
choice kind of vibe it's just something
you should do because of your family
because of the religion but then she's
also super devout Muslim it's just a
hairy topic can the disagreer please
step
forward yeah I mean I would agree in the
fact that brainwash is a very strong
word just like you said um yet you still
step forward um I'm not familiar with
anyone on this set so for me to call
someone that I don't know brainwashed I
would feel that it's pretty
disrespectful especially not knowing
where they came from what their beliefs
are why their lifestyle is the way that
it is um so I don't really see how that
kind of goes
together I just think any kind of uh
philosophy that
doesn't encourage you to ask questions
to challenge it to you know seek further
truth I I I think that should
automatically kind of be a little bit of
a red flag to kind of say this is the
one truth and everybody else might be uh
getting maybe closer or further from the
truth um so while I like see where
you're coming from I don't agree
that people are brainwashed because I do
not want to disrespect your experience I
think it may seem a certain way but it
might not be the truth for everybody and
I also want to touch up on like you
talked about how um you can't question
something I think for me for years I
like really struggled with my faith like
I I don't remember being a child and
like praying because I have to pray but
praying because like I felt like there
were repercussions that I would have to
face if I didn't pray and it wasn't
until I got to leave my house house and
go to college and like experience Islam
on my own that I had a good association
with it but I also believe that Islam is
one of the religions that does encourage
like questioning like it says if you
have doubts I will have answers I just
wanted to make a note I this is my May
and maybe it's my personal experience
growing up Muslim and I went to an
Islamic Academy I was hijabi after
fourth grade years you have to be um and
I had religion class every day and I
will just say I feel like every question
I had is met with because the Quran says
so that's it like I date someone who's
not has no background in Islam or didn't
grow up that way you're going to get met
with because the Quran says so because
Allah deems it so and it that is why the
reason that I disagree that the other
side is brainwash is because I think for
the other side to be brainwashed there
would have to be one specific truth one
version of Islam that no one can
question and everyone accepts as a truth
I think that one truth that doesn't
exist and that different people believe
in different versions of Islam so
because a lot of Muslims including
Muslim Scholars have been coming to
different interpretations and if you
were brainwashed you would be you would
not be able to come to that difference
of opinion you would simply follow what
the the scholars of the past said hi I'm
Jade and I'm a member of the
middleground patreon and I was chosen to
read the next prompt women and men are
equal in the eyes of Allah
I think a lot of people misconstrue
about Islam and when they say that women
are mistreated in Islam it just comes
from the fact that men and women were
created for different purposes now that
that doesn't mean that one holds more
value than the other and that one is
seen as better as an atheist um now I I
still uh hold that uh is Islam does come
from a feminist place um you see uh
women in positions of leadership so
despite you know my being on this side I
I I still um appreciate that Islam has
uh that perspective I grew up overseas I
grew up in Bangladesh and growing up in
a country that seemed like a lot of
things are not fair for women a lot of
things are not fair for minorities um
and I think I struggled with that
thought like okay if men and women are
equal in the eyes of Allah then why does
this exist and what I realized As I Grew
Older was that we're also living in a
society so I definitely have to face the
repercussions of like other people and
the social construct that we have right
the systems outside of it yeah the
system outside of it so like our
experiences are a product of like what
we believe in exactly and but also like
our position within the system and I I
won't put the fact that like Society
sees women as not equal onto God and
onto my religion because that's not what
religion was meant to be and I'm not
going to say that Islam does not believe
that women and men are not
[Music]
equal this was one of the biggest topics
that caused me to really doubt my faith
looking at the Quran looking at the
authentic Hadith and also just from
historical records as well men are
allowed to have sex with female slaves
in Surah n verse 24 it says prohibited
to men are married women except for what
your right hat possesses and your right
hat possessions refers to female slaves
and we see multiple Hadith of instances
where the men have just defeated the
tribe they have female work Afters and
Muhammad allowed them to have sex with
them and that's probably going to be
rape because what woman would be
consenting to sex in that
situation I think too like just thinking
about the Quran and my upbring like I
had every day the two biggest ones that
come out stand out to me would be like
the issue of the hijab which I know a
lot of people will counter so the Quran
says women have to cover thear to cover
up so that they don't tempt um the men
and then the I will say the Quran does
technically say men's hijab is their
gaze the male gaze and I just that just
seems a little silly to me beyond that
like in the Quran how men can have up to
four wives but women can't it's like I
or I in the Islamic school I want to say
the Aon the call to prayer all the boys
in my class they're like we're going to
do the call to prayer for this Friday
um I'm ineligible cuz I'm a woman
apparently can't do the isan I can't do
the call to prayer so just those are I
would say are my cor on specific
examples and they're like well this is
to protect women I don't see that at all
yeah so there's a lot of different
points that you brought up the first one
being the hijab which the woman is
obligated to wear and you talked about
how the men have to lower their gaze
which is 100% right the women also have
to lower their gaze and the men actually
have their own hijab so the men have
their own parts of their body that needs
to be covered as well so obviously men
and women were created um both
physically different and psychologically
all different types of they're different
in every single way there's different
parts of the body that need to be
covered because men are attracted to
different things when attracts to
different things it's to protect both
sides the second thing that you brought
up I believe you mentioned the you not
being able to make the call to prayer um
once again that's in order to protect
the woman just because men can also be
attracted to the voice of women so
that's the reason that that's not
allowed and I completely understand that
you being a young child that's something
that you wanted to do and I mean pre
puberty um in your household when with
your with your family that's something
that you should feel free to practice
make the call to prayer do that in front
of your father your brothers your uncles
it doesn't matter it doesn't need to be
in front of the whole entire mosque so
there may be things that you felt
because you were a woman you were being
limited to but there's a benefit behind
it so it's about looking into that I
think this is bringing up an important
important point of contention here with
all the things that you're saying and
you keep bringing up that men and women
are fundamentally different where is
that coming from where is what coming
from when you say those things when I
say what men and women are fundamentally
different in these very specific ways
men are attracted to a woman's voice
okay so scientifically U men and women
are different so if you were just look
at someone man and I look at a woman I'm
pretty sure I would see some differences
um as well as just scientifically
biologically emotionally psychologically
there's been studies because everyone
started to question you being able to
change your sex and be able to change
your gender but you were created as a
certain sex for a reason and each I
would so that's my point of contention
here I there's nothing there's nothing
for me there when you say that I was
created for a specific purpose and a
woman was created for a specific purpose
I would disagree completely why can't I
fulfill those other purposes when you
start slowly building upon these layers
these layers of like roles that that
prescriptive prescriptive roles that
starts to create a system of Oppression
yeah order that's how it's built well
can I say for personally myself um I I
would say that his view of it is also an
interpretation as much as there's Merit
to it covering my hair and my face for
me was so that people see my personality
and my intellect before they see my
beauty or they see the things that
they're attracted to also in my culture
I'm ethnically black obviously um well
maybe not obviously but um our hair is
very different from other races and we
go to Great Lengths to assimilate and
that was something that I personally
struggled with before converting so for
me yeah um it just it helped me gain
confidence I would be worried about like
am I how does my face look is there
something on my face or some of your
communication is also in your facial
expression so when you can't see some of
it you have to kind of you know use your
imagination a little bit I like that
mysteriousness I like that especially
other men don't have that access because
I'm have a fiance I like that there's
only one person who can see these parts
of me um and that's what makes it
special in a way so the roles for men
and women it's not entirely just because
I want you to do it because I said so
it's probably because it's to your
benefit if you look I talk to your point
that Allah actually says in the Quran
that like there's no compulsion in
religion So when you say that why can't
I do XYZ like why can't I do the other
role for example right these are things
that because Allah expects you to these
are the things best for you but it's not
that you can't do these things but when
you say it's best for me there's a
threat the problem is there's always
going to be an existential threat saying
it's best for you because it's what's
best for society so everything that
Allah puts in place for us that we
believe God the reason that we have
these specific if you want to say roles
because men complement women in a
certain way and women complement men in
a certain way what I'm saying is he's
not when you let me let me let me
explain myself all right let me give you
a very easy way to understand that I'll
use her point right so you mentioned
that for example why can you not marry
four husbands and why can I marry four
wives right these things have less to do
with equality or worthiness in the eyes
of Allah and just individual ual sex
differences for example if I have four
wives right I can impregnate all of them
and we'll all know who the father is and
who the mother is if you for example in
this scenario you have four husbands we
won't actually know who the father is
and also why is that important why would
that happen why does that make men and
women equal in the eyes of Allah like
that's what that's telling you so I'm
saying we're equal but we're different
there's no knowing of the father that's
just reducing women to the sole purpose
of of reproduction I don't think it's
that men you know you can impregnate
someone every day and women you know we
kind of have to stay pregnant for a
while and I feel like there would be
like a mixup with praternity I you're
say genetics like like if it was just
one one man
impregnating a bunch of women you could
have a society still I understand what
you're saying but these are such narrow
like whataboutism these are such narrow
circum so let me let me ask you a
question sorry I want to hear from AA
and Janet as well yeah I think um also
here's just a food for and I already I
can guess the answer why don't y'all
wear a hijab like Vibe why why can't men
wear a hijab they are so I'm currently
in hijab right V mean on your head you
have heads women have heads so you
consider you're basically calling the
hijab a head scarf that's not what hij
is okay in and once again we already
said that the hijab for men and women is
different because we're both created
physically different so obviously the
hijab for both of them is going to be
different that statement is not really
once again you're implying that the
hijab is oppressive to women so that's
what you're implying when you're saying
that why can't men do it because are you
do you believe that the hijab is
oppressive to one uh but uh in the
deepest depths of my soul yes I
understand it can be a choice I believe
it's by you agreeing that or by you
saying that the hijab is oppressive to
women that's actually disrespectful to
our women in the religion because you're
either implying that these women can't
think for themselves and that they're
just wearing this hijab because they're
intellect or you're saying that we're
all forcing every single woman in the
religion to wear this and we're throwing
this on their head I I think we need
ackowledge how e saying that's that's by
saying that the women are being
oppressed in the religion that's because
they have to wear the hijab not black
can I jum in here and ask so these
justifications that we are seeing for
hijab do these justifications really
still have Solid Ground when we consider
that the hijab was for only one class of
women free wom slave women didn't wear
hijab and because men were allowed to
have sex with uh with slave women they
were being sexualized and objectified
when Muslim men were considering whether
they're going to purchase them yeah let
me answer that so to address your
slavery point I'll get on that in a sec
all right but the point that you're
asking if we are really equal how could
that be and you were asking if we all
had hijab why do you have to cover your
head with a and I don't right a very
simple example is if I expect a man and
a woman to lift a heavy load but the
same load that would be unequal right so
we have to look at it is it equality or
Equity so what is equal in the eyes of
Allah for a man is not going to be the
same treatment for a woman and I'm sure
we understand that if there are
differences in our sex then there has to
be difference in expectations and roles
maybe historically but we live in a time
where a lot of what you're saying just
isn't relevant I'm not going to be found
in a situation thank you um I would love
to wrap this up and I would love it if
the women would wrap it up I would say I
feel like it's very rooted in es when it
comes to covering up for example it's to
protect you and if you are dressed IM
modestly they might react a certain way
they're attracted to your voice I just
have to say I am a lesbian and I am not
tempted by like in my mind I don't see a
woman walking down the street IM
modestly and it's not rooted in equality
like the prompt said Allah sees both
when men and women is equal and I don't
hear that honestly at all when you're
saying thank you I would love the whole
I'm we we're going to keep going and all
of this is going to build on each other
I would really love to hear from AA okay
thank you so much guys there are a
couple points I want to touch up on I
really like appreciate the uncomfortable
things that you brought up in this
conversation and I loved how like a lot
of you guys didn't respond I couldn't
respond myself um and then like she
brought up a point and then everyone
kind of jumped onto that because that is
something you guys could respond to um
and I think like there are uncomfortable
things that like especially us as women
like have questioned um that a lot of
times don't get answered and then I also
want to say like you brought up a point
or we were talking about like oh you're
that she's what she said was like
disrespect disrespectful to Muslim women
that's not true because women around the
world have different experiences they
are women who are being forced to wear
the hijab you can't disregard somebody's
life experience and be like no you don't
live in that social area you could live
like this when you're part of a system
that you don't have that same level of
like openness to it's hard to be like
it's hard to see that you know MH it is
impossible to live a 100% pure Islamic
life in modern
society join our middleground patreon to
watch this exclusive
prompt I have lost lost relationships
because of my current religious
beliefs the relationships that I've lost
would be relationships that I probably
shouldn't have been in in the first
place once I became more strong in my
faith I had to cut those people off so
those are only relationships that I've
lost yes it hurt maybe at the time but I
look at it from the outside perspective
was the decision that I had to make a
relationship that I've lost is in a
different sense than losing contact with
them but I the relationship I lost with
them is that I'm unable to be my true
self around them and that relationship
is with my mother and it's the reason
why I'm in this ridiculous outfit today
because if my mother ever found out that
her only child is going to go to hell
forever cuz he left Islam it's going to
hurt her so badly I saw myself how much
it hurt my mom when I was talking openly
about my uh doubts in Islam in high
school it was causing her like literal
depression the reason I continue to
pretend and I like I don't really have
The Bravery to come out and be my true
self around her is because she's the
best mom I could have ever asked for she
did she worked so hard to raise me she
sacrificed so much to give me a really
happy childhood and the idea that I will
showing her that all her hard work was
for nothing because her child is going
to burn in hell forever I can't hurt her
like that again like I heard her in the
past she doesn't deserve to be hurt she
deserve to be
happy I would say I haven't lost any
relationships as far as like dating and
I am no contact with my family but it's
actually not because of the difference
in religion it's because of a plethora
of other things um I would say I went to
that Islamic Academy growing up and
ironically it was a best years of my
life I had the best friends when I went
to a secular school I'm from a
conservative area so I was the only
Iranian so they were bullying me for
being hairy and then when I went to the
Islamic Academy I didn't have that
problem anymore it wasn't until when I
went to high school and I'm like
distancing myself from Islam that a lot
of people from our local community um
just kind of like there's Whispers of oh
Janet's family is Hypocrites she's a
because I don't dress modestly as
honestly as they'd like me to um etc etc
um I've lost a lot of I would say my
Muslim friends from the school thank you
for sharing guys I also want to say I
think I have a very similar experience
with you I would say that there were
quite a few years of my life when I was
really really questioning my faith but
also like the way I grew up and what was
like I would say forced upon me um and
it was really hard because I felt like
not myself because of how conservative
my family was was I As I Grew Older we
just started becoming like separated
because of their viewpoints and as like
as they grew older they became more and
more religious and to a point where I
felt like sometimes like if I'm trying
to like share my feelings something like
that's really difficult and I've gone
through like very difficult situations
in my life um I'd be met with like So
Many religious things I felt like
misunderstood by my siblings a lot when
like when I was questioning my religion
I felt like I had to keep that secret
and it wasn't until end of my high
school career where like I was sitting
with my best friend who is very Muslim
and one of the best people I've ever met
and I shared she was like the first
person I shared and it took so much
courage to share that and then she said
you're not horrible for questioning a
religion you're just human and I think
that changed my life and I think that's
what I would say to anyone that's like
watching this video I would say that to
anybody who's like questioning like
you're just human that does not make you
bad and like especially if you're a
Muslim and you're like afraid of like
what Allah thinks of you Allah does not
think of you badly
so I I just think I'm in in a pretty
privileged position my dad's half Jewish
um but baptized Catholic my stepmom was
raised Southern Baptist I have Mormon
cousins I have Quaker uh family I've
I've just had to all my life learn how
to agree to disagree with with certain
things um and um and just be sensitive
um across beliefs but that isn't to say
I I don't feel like I've lost
some connection for sure with my really
devout Muslim family um I I haven't told
them that I'm queer um my mother came
out she was married to a woman for for
for a while so um you know they at least
know that but um at least you know with
the conservative part of my family um
they've proven that they're not a safe
space and that's that um I've lost some
relationships because of me reverting
it's more so because people couldn't
relate to me anymore because I used to
be very different I used to be that girl
who would like go to Raves with my
friends my favorite rapper is stun a
girl like I I'm from Sacramento like I
wasn't raised Muslim so all the friends
that I had growing up and stuff when I
started to become a little bit more
conservative or a little bit more
intentional with the things that I
wanted out of life they were kind of
like why don't you want to go with me
until like you know clubbing or do this
and I'm like because I want to have a
family like I want to make sure that I'm
the type of person that I would choose
if I was a man and I realized that um
when I became an adult and so because of
that
people we just went our separate ways
Islamic views on homosexuality are
outdated so I grew up in a pretty queer
family my South Asian family is very uh
Muslim and my mother and her sisters
grew up in that environment um and all
three of them turned out to be queer I'm
queer my sister's queer it was a long
journey of self-acceptance and this is
just who we are and who we've always
been when I when I look at my
grandfather he and I have strikingly
similar stories he admits that in his
village it was normal for men before
they were married to play around with
each other to have boyfriends um uh to
experiment but then after you were an
adult after you kind of after you
married of course that that was off the
table but I I kind of see you know
almost 70 years apart me and him both
have the same stories early 20s got to
experiment with my sexuality you know
now in a long-term relationship with a
girl and and very secure in that but uh
his experience was filled with shame
that that he then passed on to his
daughters so uh I just I I see that and
I feel bad for generations of of queer
people who have been uh told that they
can't be um or that maybe they can be
but they can't act upon it because that
is Haram some way um so queerness is in
our blood it's in our nature it's across
species it's across time it's across
history and uh religion through Islam
through Christianity um and through
various other means um have been used as
as tools to erase that queer history I
agree all abrahamic all religion in
general organized religion I feel like
it's not you're going to find it
Christianity and Judaism um I I myself
I'm a lesbian I didn't come out until I
was older like an adult but a lot of
that was rooted because I have such
devout Muslim family it's like it's if I
come out like my mind's going many
places it's not just going to be like a
normal American family coming out like I
have very abrasive Muslim dad I don't
really see my gayness coinciding with um
religion like an organized religion I
think that Islam has no moral standing
to say that two consenting queer adults
can't be in love while allowing a man to
have sexual relationships with his slave
I couldn't rationalize how that is okay
but to gay or lesbian or whatever adults
who are in a loving relationship they're
fully consensual there's no power
Dynamic is that's
bad my question is if it's okay for to
consenting for example males who have
love for each other to conduct sexual
intercourse then what is the problem
with um two brothers who have love for
each other and they're consenting to
have sex that's not the same how the
same incest and you're comparing incest
and homosexuality that's that's you're
please explain the difference I'm the
difference
offive either way either wayl the
difference explain the difference it's
very because morality one is I've done a
23 and me me and my girlfriend are not
related at all so what is the difference
what is the difference they're both
can I say something can I say something
that's as wrong as a brother and a
sister consenting and having sex exactly
so what's the problem with that what do
you
mean homosexuality okay because they
both come from the same point there's
two people who consent to having sex
together same exact thing so
what methods of socialization what is
the what is the problem with them if
they both consenting and they both have
love for each other just like two males
who don't know each other have love for
each other what is the problem problem
just to say you just did this thing in
speaking called minimizing an issue and
then you're trying to find this
correlation that I'm doing is actually
addressing the principle which is coming
from objective morality so I'm trying to
figure out what I'm trying to figure out
if this is wrong if homosexuality is
okay then what makes incest not
okay let me say what you are bringing up
is not relevant it is not it has nothing
to do it has nothing to do with two who
are not related it has everything to do
they're not on the same princip let's
let people talk for like at Le want talk
I get interrupted so no we're not going
to do that you're
interrup it's offensive for you to make
arguments when every time I'm getting
interrupted I let y'all speak every
single time and then I I just want this
question answered like simply put what's
wrong with two brothers can I answer the
question please please okay so I feel
like what it's very obvious that incest
is wrong because one if you have a child
with this person there might be
something wrong with it not to mention
that if somebody has known you since you
were born the influence that they'll
have over your life is different than if
you made the choice to actually be with
them that's why it's wrong here's the
thing about homosexuality because you
would think that I'm homophobic because
you know like I guess everybody assumes
I'm like extra Pious and whatever
because I cover my face right actually
one of my parents um is a member of the
LGBT community I grew up with some
cousins that were I had friends that
where all throughout elementary school
and high school and stuff I never
saw
um morally something wrong with it I
think that the reason that it was put
into Quran it is simply about
sustainability you can't sustain life on
Earth if people like the majority of the
population are homosexual I don't think
it was to say that anybody's better than
anybody else we all have the capacity
for love we all just want to love and be
loved my question is the idea there's
two consenting individuals that want to
have sexual intercourse regardless of
their backgrounds what is wrong with
that because we don't we're not saying
that that's the only determiner here
we're saying between two men who have
not grown up together who are not
brother brother and brother so it's two
different things they are two different
things okay so let's say there's two
estang brothers that never grew up
together my honest interview can we
pause I would like to hear uh Jad you
can make a final statement I'd like to
hear from AA um and can we keep it about
homosexuality so let close up incest you
want to bring up the point about how
incest results in there's obviously
things that come harm that can come from
that there's also harm that has been
proven to come from homosexual
intercourse and a man having interourse
with other man um all the
STDs 100% but there it's been
scientifically proven that STDs are more
in homosexual relationships heterosexual
people get STDs too so your argument of
homosexual people get homosexual people
are getting creating there's new STDs
that are resulting from this type of
interourse that's happening and it's
found a
lot perf so a very recent scientifically
proven one was monkey Puck that the
overwhelming
literature lit you saying you were
projecting a stereotype it literally
became a stereotype against gay men How
is scientific literature a
stereotype it was you're what what are
you s uh sourcing here cuz every you're
you have clearly believed all of the
Google articles about how it was only
attributed to the gay community that's
my opinion that's it monkey pox was
ridiculous um I I really wish that this
conversation was like a bit more about
like the impact the fact that it's
sinful in Islam and like the effect that
it has on like youth um I think that
like I firsthand know the experience and
the hardship people go through when they
grow up in a community when they have
never even heard of homosexuality and
then the first time they hear about it
is disgust the way our societies are
structured we ha hate on the fact that
they even exist we don't want our
children to be that we don't want people
in our communities to be around that we
don't want to allow people who are
homosexual in our MOS sorry I'm getting
really emotional about this because
there are just so many people I've seen
there are so many people who have lost
their lives because they just could not
exist and so to minimize somebody's life
and to like hate on them for this one
part of their life that is so that's
supposed to be so private is not okay
and it's not Islamic um personally I
didn't step in here to say that it's
outdated because I don't want to make a
statement about my faith that I wasn't
this is something that I always
struggled with but I'm not going to say
it's outdated because I just don't know
why it is the way it is and I choose not
to question it because I'm a Muslim but
at the same time I do have like a lot of
pain associated with that that truth um
because I have seen how that impacts
people's lives um and I think that like
at the end of the day like I wish we
lived in a world where we saw the fact
that like as human beings we have free
will therefore just how I have the free
will to practice my religion and like
not entertain a homosexual relationship
the same way anybody
else has the ability to not be religious
to practice homosexuality and to coexist
respectfully and that's something that
sometimes Muslims can't offer and that
is my problem um and I wish we offered
that so that we wouldn't lose people's
lives the way that we do we wouldn't
push people away we wouldn't traumatize
them and generations to come and I 100%
agree with that the fact that um it's
very important that we understand
regardless of what Islamic points and my
points obviously coming from Islam are
on homosexuality that that means that in
no way whatsoever am I going to
blatantly disrespect you for the way
that you're living your life just
because I deep down inside reject not
even deep down just inside I reject your
lifestyle um that doesn't mean that I'm
going to come out here and start
blatantly disrespecting you and saying
anything about the way that you're
living your life if that's the way that
you're going to live your life that's
the way that you're going to live your
life and at the end of the day we
believe that that it's going to be God
that's going to be the one judging you
and it's not up to me Muslims are
unfairly targeted by
[Music]
Outsiders I have to say this is an
interesting I just have to think for a
really long time no yeah fair enough
honestly just being from the Middle East
in general you're going to get targeted
I went to a conservative secular school
and I was the only Iranian kid there and
they automatically just assume I'm
Muslim because I'm Iranian they have
such like disdain for it I've had um
in-laws from several people I dated um
like as soon as they start dating me
send things about Isis and the Taliban
like articles and for which is
ridiculous because even as an ex-muslim
I know that's not Islam I'm pretty
protective because of it even as an
ex-muslim like I if I hear anything
disparaging I'll jump on it because I
just feel like people are really
islamophobic I agree yeah islamophobia
is real I experienced it myself as a kid
and I know the topic was about Outsiders
but I have actually noticed this issue
with other ex-muslims like some
ex-muslims when they leave their faith
they become really islamophobic and they
become really dead set on this idea that
Islam is you're supposed to go and and
attack disbelievers you're supposed to
do Jihad
like Isis and Al-Qaeda does I mean they
contribute to how The Outsiders would
unfairly think that a lot of Muslims are
uh just terrorists that like they want
to do Jihad but the truth is the most
the average Muslim today in America is a
peaceful a person um I just have one
point to add I really agree with this
that like especially in the United
States yes we're definitely targeted um
even if you look like slightly Muslim
you're targeted even like being Muslim
from a different sect of the world a
different part of the world like gets
you targeted um a lot of times my dad
because I'm we are South Asian when we
go out to like the Middle East like
anywhere in the Middle East they attack
him because they think that his
salvation um even though he's like
Muslim and they can see it and my mom's
wearing a hijab but I really agree with
that but at the same time I also believe
that there is another part of the truth
that like there are places where there's
violence occurring and Muslims are like
also part of that problem um so in that
they are also the people who are hurting
others and also being hurt and it's like
a cycle of violence I also like the
point that you brought up I think
extremism is a problem no matter which
sector whether that's like a extremist
Muslim or an extremist from any religion
so I think that problem exists on both
aisles um everything y'all say is pretty
valid I mean it's not that I don't think
Muslims get like unfairly targeted I
think just everyone gets targeted
nowadays so so it's just like yes after
9/11 I think right after that it
definitely got a little bit tough for a
lot of Muslims I think it was like
severe targeting at that time um I think
now I don't think it's as bad as it used
to be um still every once in a while
you'll experience something like maybe
me cuz my beard like you'll get like a
look or something or someone will just
throw a comment but it's nothing to the
point where I'm like I'm like hurt like
oh my God like how could you say I just
want to add I think it's a little
different for students who like kids who
are in school I a lot of them um I've
had
like students who have told me like even
like the past year like how they have
had they they were discriminated against
um and so I would say that like I think
it still exists yeah what I found for
the most part is it it definitely like
even when I was in school like yeah I
got made fun of or whatever people would
do jokes that like terrorist jokes or
whatever but once you I just like I was
the type of person I wouldn't just sit
down and like let someone make that joke
about me someone made this exact joke in
school and like like about like a bomb
blowing up or something cuz we were
watching a documentary and so I in front
of the whole class I addressed them I
addressed the reason why did you make
that joke I explained my point of view
and then and then he got expelled so I
think if you just let them make these
jokes about you and you just sit back
and kind of take it then yeah the bullly
is just going to keep on attacking that
you definitely handled that situation
better than I did as a kid cuz in
elementary school someone called me in
PE class he called me a terrorist I said
if I was a terrorist you would be dead
right now and what happened was I got a
one day suspension while he got a lunch
detention I think I think it's important
to note like while I think there's
definitely some validity in what you're
saying for sure like it's important to
stand up for yourself for your beliefs
for your religion um I don't I think we
need to acknowledge that it's not always
that easy and there's definitely
circumstances where I think the opposite
is true I think there's just as much
true that like somebody can go through
their life and it will get worse for
them because even so early on we're
talking about times like we were young
children and we were exposed to these
horrible maor of things and um maybe
those people have circumstances where
when they go through life it's just
going to get worse they're just going to
they're going to have even more hatred
they're going to there's going to be
more reasons for them to come at it in a
way that's dangerous my personal desires
do not have a place in Islamic
faith for me other than like the obvious
I'm part of the LGBT community I was
raised Muslim and I felt like I didn't
have decisions or choices growing up
when it came to Islam I remember I'd
question things in my religion class I
remember like the Imam told me like
women when you go to hedge you can't
wear um like body spray right or perfume
and I raised my hand during um my
religious class and I asked why and I
always got met with well because the
Quran says so like be quiet Janet's the
problematic kid asking me questions um I
just feel like there's no room really
there even without the LGBT community
part of me like what you want kind of it
felt like doesn't matter there's no room
for it it's just it is what it is and
you need to obey it at the end of the
day if you commit a sin and you don't
seek repentance you're Allah is going to
punish you for it even if your personal
desires conflict with that because of
that looming threat it does not matter
what you want if it goes against what
Allah says then you are risking having
your bones crushed in the grave or you
are risking having your skin burned off
of your face it doesn't matter how
illogical you think it is if you believe
in Islam and Allah says it's bad and you
go against that you are putting yourself
at a huge risk of a lot of pain and
suffering yeah I think it's not that it
doesn't have room for our desires
because it does it just doesn't have
room for our
compulsions and I heard this quote
someone said my religion is perfect but
I am not you have to allow Islam to
teach you that you've blurred the lines
between your desires and your
compulsions and the things that you
actually need out of life so it's really
hard to be connected to God if you're
connected to all these things that are
calling you pulling you different
directions can I ask you a question yeah
so does your standard for Haram and
Halal vary at all what would you base
your standard off of how were you taught
those
standards um I learn them from Quran
Quran or from my upbringing if I don't
know so oh yeah yeah so I think
everything you're saying is valid and I
think you can also believe all these
things even just like outside of Islam
like I think these principles have
existed like throughout time other
religions other philosophies and so my
question is like when it comes to the
more sort of confusing like I was raised
I'm not allowed to eat pork okay so
that's I'm sure yeah
nobody same right and so uh I think I
think at one point somebody told me that
was because they're not safe to eat or
like you know it's dirty point being
there are moments like you can you can
definitely live your life that way but
my question is like at what point do you
question those those nuances those like
those confus first first I question why
I'm questioning it it's like why do I
want to have a different answer than
what's written here first I question
that okay and then I'll do research and
I'll say okay well how will people live
living like before my time before my
parents before my grandparents and why
didn't they choose to eat this animal
well maybe because it eats its own feal
matter or it eats its children I mean
you know it's its own fetus and stuff
like that I understand what I'm saying
is like how do you deal with the the
logic of it because there's many ways to
argue around it if I can't is okay if I
interject here thank you so essentially
yeah there's a lot of things that you
may not understand why something's
essentially what you're saying is if
something is not allowed and you don't
understand why it's not allowed how do
you kind of go about being okay with
with this thing not being allowed if God
is telling us not to do something or to
do something even if we don't understand
the wisdom behind it it's the fact that
we know that he's the most knowledgeable
so we trust in the fact that whatever
he's telling us to do or not to do that
is the best thing for us blind fa blind
loyalty yeah so blind loyalty um in
terms of yeah this because we believe
that he is the most knowledgeable so I
do question obviously if something I
don't understand something I'll ask
someone of more knowledge and if they
can't give me an answer as to why
something is the way that it is then we
believe believe that Allah and his
Prophet know what's best and at that
point I believe put my faith in God
that's what faith is i i i there's
there's just a a small hiccup in both of
your like scientific method here which
is that why am I questioning and then
then there's your part if I don't get
the right answer or an answer that makes
sense to me I keep asking I keep asking
I keep asking but if you don't get it
then there's this kind of cognitive
dissonance that now needs to exist I
think I think I think like a good way to
put it is like part of existing as a
human being is questioning everything
that's how we developed everything
that's how we grow and adapt I want to
add something really quick I know that
like there's been a lot of questions
with what he said especially you guys
saying like that's Blind Faith I think
that there is like I see your point but
there's a lot of Merit and like I agree
that like meaning of life is questioning
things however if you keep questioning
everything you're going to have the most
doubtful horrible untrusting life in the
entire universe the like the goal is of
life is to be in peace right so I think
that like we can only question some of
the things and I think personally from
my questioning I have found the answers
to which that has led me to trust the
God that I believe in and that is why I
also believe in the other things that he
sub he tells me to subscribe to because
I believe that that is good for me so
it's not always that every Muslim or
anybody who subscribes to religion is
like blindly believing in everything no
they have a trusting relationship with
that form of God or that religion or
that ideology and therefore they choose
to subscribe to other ideals yeah I
totally relate I I there's a lot of
insecurity here um there's there's a lot
of Doubt um there's a lot of thinking I
just I I think it is a much more
difficult and much more Noble Path to
take you know through the chaos through
the unknown um through the lack of of
prescription through questioning um
rather than just kind of taking the
carrot and the Stick Of Heaven and Hell
and and saying that that's you know
those are my answers and and that brings
me Comfort I I think that there are
paths
to being a good human um outside of
religion and I believe earnestly that
those paths are much harder to take my
question to you would be like where do
you draw the line we all draw the
line where our morality is I feel like
there's like a general sense
of others usually right so I'm saying if
we were all left to just decide what is
okay and what is not okay do you guys
not see that it would just be left to
individual opinions no I think there's I
think there's like a pretty basic
understanding just as a human of what's
right and wrong I'm just a really
scientific person I'm going to do my
research I have Engineers for parents so
that gives me peace yeah so it's my
different kind of piece I don't think
people are just atheists or
non-religious people are running rampant
without a set of rules I think just to
be a good person religion aside there's
just pretty standard things that you
should just follow I see your point of
view and I think that that's why like
what she said and what you said like I
understand both of you so equally
because I feel like at parts of my life
I struggled with feeling so much guilt
like I felt like Islam put so much like
guilt on me of like oh if I do this I'm
going to go to hell I felt like a really
anxious person but then once I actually
started becoming closer to God I had a
safer relationship with him or or them
um and I believed that like no first
like God is here for me like there are
so many times in my life I felt so alone
and like when I read the Quran like I
really feel that now that like no matter
who is hurting me like Allah is with me
and I think that has been like something
that has made me really strong so I
think that like yes people have a moral
compass but at the end of the day like
as I know from my studies like it is
dependent on culture and if there was no
like guidance people would still create
one that was a beautiful way to end
thank you guys so much my nice
me very interesting let's
go
[Applause]
sir